foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome welcome everybody
NBA bets we love uh
guys coming after after last week I
don't know how I'm feeling I don't know
how I'm feeling we just came off a loss
but Howard how are y'all feeling on this
fine Monday afternoon
wait wait wait wait we came off one loss
but we gave all hella winners last week
we went one and one we hit some first
baskets we hit some Superstar Fades we
actually had a pretty profitable week I
would say
if you look at it from that perspective
MB I agree uh we did go one-on-one we we
we won a parlay it was plus money
so yeah I agree Ryan talk to me how you
feeling on this Monday Bro I'm
personally coming off a loss but
everyone else is coming off a win which
is a win for because it's like you
should have been I mean of course I was
tailing the rest of the picks I ended up
a winner so it's you know I feel great
right this feels like a great a great
day a great night to end the NBA season
strong because for our lovely Miami Heat
fans who are here your season ends
tonight uh it's over all over it is it's
all over with it's over right and I hate
to see it I hate to see it Ryan is
calling the series Ryan is calling the
series
he's calling it he's calling game he's
calling you you would be so shocked to
see that KJ Mullins jumped in the chat
no no
shout out KJ Mullins bro yeah that that
person's been in here every show I I man
that's a Super Fan that's a super we
need to send them some some socks or
something shout out to you yeah for real
for real KJ Mullins if you hit up one of
us on Instagram you know I'm saying hit
up one of our DMS we get you some some
stuff out to your uh to your home but I
want to welcome everybody else to the
show welcome to the show my name is Greg
Ivory to your left
is producer Ryan my man he's over here I
always do this he's over here
producer Ryan and to your right is a man
I call him MB y'all might know him as
Michael Bolin but he is the man of the
app
um drop your Best Bets for tonight's NBA
Finals game five in the chat we're
looking to bounce back after
last week we went one-on-one we talked
about this already we won 101 we had a
decent week last week but we're looking
to bounce back heat nuggets Brian what
are the people talking about in the chat
uh bath that boys in here says me
Familia what's Good Fellas
uh Mike 23 catch we tapped in
uh gauge highs uh brown one plus steel
um
I don't think we can oh I think we uh we
actually could uh same game parlay that
I believe Let's uh oh did Ryan figure it
out
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man I don't know if you should that
sounds like a really good play to me
damn I kind of right I mean you could
click it if you wanted to throw it in
there dude
we sold this as a as a ten to one parlay
we're starting out with minus 3.90. ah
this is gonna be an uphill battle I knew
what he was gonna say bro you got to see
one go through right like no
I guess damn that's so funny all right
here we go oh bagel and locks Tyler hero
under six and a half points has to be
has to be
has to be I don't know I don't know I
don't think so bro yeah listen listen I
know I don't want I don't want to spoil
any picks that are coming later but
Tyler hero is going to play this game
tonight and the numbers for everybody
else suggest that he's gonna get a good
amount of run tonight so I don't know
man that's three baskets bro in his
world we gotta think about it we gotta
think about the heat need offense what
does Tyler Herobrine he brings against
the Heat
yeah don't you think they're going to
give them shots
I mean now now we are betting if he's
going to make those shots but
I bet I think he's gonna get a lot of
those shots that you know the heat is
looking for to score
um I don't know man all right I see uh
I see young 24 saying jokic 10 assists I
like this for one big reason I do think
he gets a triple double tonight but
I think he doesn't care and I know that
because he expresses it all the time but
if he gets 11 assists tonight he will
average a triple double for the series
so that seems like a decent play I'm
sure it's cake though I mean yeah okay
he's been doing crazy numbers bro
MB look at you I'm out here trying to
eat man it might be the last day it
might be our last day bro it really it
really might
um by the way uh Spider-Man uh no D
Spire not spider bam and jokic for a
block did we wait until the last NBA
show of the year to just decide that we
all wanted to Parlay defense what
happened yeah I don't know
I think yeah hey Ryan what's wrong with
that
I'm just trying to get to oh I yeah I do
actually kind of like this now that I
look at it
I mean I twist my arm
I hope that the people at home have so
much fun watching Ryan's facial
expressions the way I do because as soon
as he saw the number he was like oh yeah
I do
uh Rob Dog also shout out Rob Dog who's
in here almost all the time
um said jokic two plus threes
um and before we get to that for a
second can we just talk about my own
personal uh progression and pronouncing
his last name I mean we started out in
hell right we made some cool strides
dude dude it's yeah it's I mean it's
like it rolls off the tongue so easy now
like it's jokish I don't even I don't
even need the first name I was calling
him Nikola for a while because I was
like I don't want to pronounce the last
name I was calling him Joker sometimes
because it's like I'm running away from
it jokic it's beautiful
um two plus threes though yes sir that's
plus one yeah
yeah I like that
I gotta give a shout out to Javi ball
out here this man dropped a whole parlay
I think bagel and locks brought it to
our attention he dropped five plays in
one comment bro that's that's love he's
got it all laid out you see this oh
Murray over 25 and a half bam over 10
and a half rebounds Bruce Brown under
four rebounds jokic over nine and a half
assists
unreal he just had so many picks there
we got to pick one of them out of that
list Ryan I'll let you do it but that's
uh that's a good comment right there
that's what we like all right can we do
this process of elimination wise and
this is no yeah I'm not trying to poop
on the ticket uh everyone is on Jamal
Murray's over 25 and a half points
tonight um so I'm gonna have to yeah I'm
gonna have to sorry uh bam over ten and
a half rebounds
he's been doing that a lot uh Bruce
Brown under four rebounds is he
available he is but it's a three and a
half do we want to do that probably not
um jokic over nine and a half assists
and Aaron Gordon over 13 and a half
points
and
B made a great point about jokic and
assist I'm I'm just saying I'm that's it
we're already plugged we're already Plus
571.
if we if we like the Jimmy but I mean we
don't have to make this we don't have to
make this five legs we could make it
seven I mean it's the last day of school
we could do whatever we want do whatever
we want we can do whatever we want we
can't do whatever we want hey those
defensive those defensive legs I think
those are locked
a lot
how many yeah I like
uh I mean how many yogic legs can we
have in one parlay the limit does not
exist I feel like oh that is a good
point yeah dude just stops the statue
man like he does everything he yeah and
like I don't know if he's gonna have
back-to-back games without getting to
double digit assists
right yeah yeah I I don't see it yeah he
that's that's awesome look at that
that's
you talk about we we have done so many
things on this show where we're putting
in random Players Bench scores and we
just did a superstar parlay and in eight
minutes yep pretty much
that's how we do it and I like it it's
called progression it's called
progression it's called so we all
usually so we're all getting our
diplomas from uh parlay school this this
year we just graduated I feel like
whoa what is wrong what is Ryan over
there doing uh yeah sorry I I'm reacting
to the chat in real time here uh I am
listening to you guys but uh bath Ave
boy said Aaron Gordon six plus rebounds
has hit every game this series his
Line's at six and a half so I'm just
trying to buy it at six and see where
that leaves us minus 190.
now we're talking big money
I don't hate it how many legs is that
that's six and that gives us the
opportunity if we want to buy down
something because like air Gordon six
plus if if bath Ave boy and let me
double check his you know I'll bat that
boy I would take you at your word every
day but it's you know it would be
malpractice if I didn't double check
um you know what they say about when
people say but it's like forget
everything they said before they said
that word so he's also by the way he's
correct he's correct he's gone in this
series he's gone six seven ten seven so
I like the six why don't we tease down
the jokic threes oh what's this is
moving in real time oh well yeah Gordon
numbers
let's just make it so we have one three
okay uh we want to be yeah oh wait so we
want to do the threes instead of the
assists or we want to do both we could
probably do both could do both yeah
let's
do the yeah
but we're we're like Pepe silvying for
everyone here so that's just like well
let's take a step back we'll review what
we're what we got and then we'll talk
about what we want to change so
we've got Jimmy Butler one plus steel
bam out of Bio OnePlus block uh Nikolai
jokic one plus Bach uh jokic over one
and a half made threes jokic over nine
and a half assists Aaron Gordon six plus
rebounds that's six legs right now at
plus 17.50
um
yeah I say let's bring the let's bring
the threes down to one for yogic so we
don't have to worry about two makes I
think that's probably the best place to
start that's I mean you want to talk
about
cake that's gonna be one
uh let's see let's see let's see
ah
we'll get this over ten it does but then
we can't move the assists
I feel like I'm better with the dude I
don't know if you watched last game I
almost had a mental breakdown but when
Jamal Murray dribbles the ball it's like
the heat defense forgets somehow that
everyone else exists like yeah was like
the only dude in the 305 area code on
the perimeter for a few of his shots
because he was shooting that far last
game yeah yeah he was Steph Curry I
think I think that I think that's just a
part of the game plan like I think the
heat are going to be fine with him
shooting threes but he's making him and
he's making it look easy yeah I say
let's keep his over one and a half and
let's buy down the assists
okay cool with that all right yup yup
yup I like that Ryan
I like that play so we're going to keep
the over one and a half threes we're
gonna buy down those assists what are we
thinking eight
yeah I like eight that's still a really
good number wait let's see if we could
do let's see if we can get cheeky here
and and sneak a little seven in oh
probably not no oh we can
stop it can we sneak six
no we can't uh okay so over six and a
half what if what if we yeah that looks
good I mean Jimmy Butler one plus steel
lock I mean we didn't we didn't really
do much different taking out the threes
though now that I think about it it's
about the same number
without the what are you doing
yeah I like I like it yeah in all
honesty I like what rain did I like I
think Jokers can make two threes he
brought those assist numbers down even
though I think I agree with you bowling
I do think he's gonna go out there and
try to create history tonight
oh yeah yeah yeah well I mean they say
right like the hardest game to win is
the closeout game obviously Miami's got
a lot of Pride they've played really
hard all playoffs but the odds are
stacked against them I would be shocked
if both Murray and jokic had relatively
mediocre games I think they're both
gonna ball tonight for sure
yeah at home
at home man
you got to do what you do best yeah yeah
hold on let me just I'm trying to double
check something here uh Conor McHugh
says uh Tyler hero is out I need to
confirm that no way
let me see let me let me let me take a
peek as well
uh it's all hands on deck we're going
with our normal rotation and then we'll
see how things play out from Eric
spolstra
[Music]
uh so how does that how that was five
minutes ago how does that lend anyone to
believe that he's out tonight yeah I
don't know unless unless uh what's his
name O'Connor maybe Connor is his friend
Walsh tweeted that he's in so I'm I'm
I'm rock and roll okay yeah uh yeah yeah
I'm not I'm not buying this also I don't
really know this that didn't really if
we don't really have anything that did
not affect the parlay at all it was just
like breaking news on the show type
thing but um yeah Ryan go go ahead and
we're locking this in let's read over
the parlay for the people uh also real
quick from Clee 15 any status on on hero
uh yes he's in per Ryan Ribeiro uh
please just make sure you always cite
your sources please yeah last day of
school don't forget
remember me uh uh okay chat's parlay
here we go uh Jimmy Butler one plus
steal bam out of Bio one plus block
Nikolai jokic one plus block Aaron
Gordon six plus rebounds Nikolai jokic
over one and a half made threes and
Nikolai jokic over six and a half
alternate assists that's six legs six
legs dude not five not four that's six
wait it went back it went up it's plus
1200 now uh oh
I mean let's see let's see about the one
three
okay I mean we have to we have I mean
yeah it would be you're right again it
would be malpractice if we didn't like
this is just what we have to do
uh
no no what just happened I I yeah
something drastically had just happened
uh something very weird just happened
just throw it back in we'll just keep it
how it is
two threes went up it went up it was I
think it's plus 128 now
um wait wait just give me give me one
sec if not I'll re I'll reread the
parlay we'll be good ah can we do can we
do Aaron Gordon four and a half
rebound let's do it yeah why not just
just in case this is a uh an outlier
um for the people right okay once you're
done locking it in read it all right so
adjusted adjustment for graphics sake
Aaron Gordon over four and a half
rebounds
here we go Jimmy Butler one plus steal
bam out of Bio one plus block Nikolai
jokic one plus block Nikolai jokic over
six and a half alternate assists
Nikolai jokic over one and a half made
threes Aaron Gordon over four and a half
rebounds
six this is money six legs
plus 10 21.
come on let's go stop playing with us
come on Brian Talk That Talk man if you
want to tell our parlay make sure you
head on over to FanDuel Ryan tell the
people what's up tell the people if they
you know if they head on over the
FanDuel in their first time user tell
them what's up if you're a first time
user and you head over to FanDuel bet
five dollars and get one hundred and
fifty dollars at bonus bets guaranteed
if I was a math guy I would tell you how
much that's multiplied by five I'm not a
math guy so I don't I don't necessarily
know that
um so I can't do that for you
unfortunately that's not the place to
come to for me but I can tell you that
150 of bonus bets are guaranteed and you
could use it however you'd like so do
that
use it however you like all right it's
time for Best Bets for tonight it's time
for best best tonight
we're gonna stay with the same rotation
Ryan you go first bowling you second I
clean it up Ryan we need you to get on
base we need you to be a rabbit here I
know so talk to us what's your best bet
for today yeah dude I popped out to
short last week that was tough
um
yeah that was brutal
um all right we're gonna go back to the
place where this all started uh at least
in the NBA finals
Caleb Martin
um now listen if you follow us on oh
it's back to 14 and a half uh if you
follow us on social you will see that
um I I could be sharp right I got it at
15 and a half this morning
um it is now at 14 and a half do I still
like that number
I do I do still like that number I am
fading Caleb Martin uh under points and
rebounds at 15 and a half but again
still like 14 and a half listen
his games in Denver have been bad and
like bad to the point where it's like he
is almost unplayable how bad he is add
into the mix Tyler hero tonight and I
think things just become a little bit
too much for Caleb Martin especially if
things start in Max truce's favor it's
just gonna be who who has the hot hand
because they're gonna be rotating
between struce Martin hero uh Duncan
Robinson so that's just like that's a
recipe for disaster and he's only gone
over this number or 15 and a half at
least once this entire series and it
happened last game and you've got all
these dudes in the mix now I just think
it's gonna be too much Caleb Martin
under
14 and a half now points of rebounds I
got it at 15 and a half
um that's my that's my best bet for
tonight's game
there it is my man Ryan locking into
Caleb Martin under MB
you're up next
I got a couple things I want to cover
here first of all I love Ryan's play
because in a game five a closeout
they're gonna have to throw everything
at the kitchen everything but the
kitchen sink and if somebody like you
said has the hot hand they're gonna be
the guy that stays in okay my bet first
of all Jamal Murray is about to have his
legacy game I can just feel it I know
that it's it's not it's a super trendy
public play everyone's over it but I'm
going way over it there is a bet on
FanDuel if you think that he can score
40 points in any of the remaining NBA
finals games you can get it at 27-1 I
will take that
27-1 if he drops 40
in this game and it's not going past
this game we know that the series is
going to end tonight so you get your
shot tonight 27-1 that man has been on a
mission and you could probably make a
small argument small teeny that he
deserves some MVP consideration in this
series because he's got more assists
than jokic at this moment and the man's
been balling so give me Murray at 27-1
to drop 40 tonight and I will sneak in
we're going back to the well with bam
out of bio for first basket that is
non-negotiable and the other pick is
Michael Porter Jr because he can't shoot
any worse than he has over the last few
games and I'm done baby let's go
the people were asking for at bowling
they were they're asking the whole show
for the first basket and now they got it
there it is
my boy MB just dropped it man he just
dropped it on y'all it's up to y'all to
listen it's up to y'all to listen but
he's rocking with Jamal Murray to score
40 plus points in any NBA Finals game
remaining he might go out with a with a
bang like MB said
um
but it's my turn it's my turn now guys
it is my turn
Ryan yes
yes you had Caleb Martin under 15 and a
half points uh and oh you had points and
rebounds right I I did yes
I can guess where this is going
I was taking the Ponder at that I was
taking a deep dive into it
and I actually connected with like a
Capper you know somebody that actually
bets for a living you know what I'm
saying
there's two different definitions of
Capper Greg okay
which one we're using dog
I specif I specifically said you know a
guy who bet on oh no what did I say what
ah shoot I lost my train of thought but
a Capper you know what I'm trying to say
a Capper somebody who professionally
bets that's what I said somebody who
bets professionally you know yeah I I
don't know if you're on that level but
you know
go ahead
I I consulted with somebody
and um
they told me the line actually moved the
line's been fluctuating all day you got
it at 15 and a half I got it at 13 and a
half it's currently at 14 and a half
um but Ryan um I'm gonna have to fade
you tonight I'm gonna have to face you
tonight and it's not me bro it's not me
it's the professional Capper it's it's
I'm believing in his picks I'm believing
in his ability to be a professional in
sports betting and he told me that uh
Caleb Martin was gonna go over 13 and a
half points in rebounds tonight so
I'm rocking with it that is exactly what
I'm doing it it's it's kind of It kind
of has something to do with you Ryan but
it doesn't you know what I'm saying
I don't know how you could I don't know
how you could successfully fade me at
this stage in my in my finals it's a
bull it's a bold strategy see how it
works out for it
I mean that was a really great
conversation you know I I played the
long game I don't I don't go off of like
you know
like a small sample size which is the
NBA finals
bro go ahead Ryan I went 13-7 in the in
the playoffs dog that's 20 bets what are
we talking about small sample size
that's a small sample size I've been in
I've been doing these shows with you
since
September or August October October bro
September yeah so I'm talking about NFL
too yeah man yeah right
that season went for me we know you we
know you like me I we know you
so what you're saying Greg is that the
guy you consulted is a Capper and Ryan
is a Capper he's not is not a capital
he's not oh here's the deal one of us is
a Capper we're gonna figure out which
one's which tonight well no no no no I
know which one I am I know which one I
am look at that right on tonight
there MB I'm so sorry bro I picked up on
what you said what is this yes Ryan is a
Capper the other guy is a Capper we have
to figure out which one is the real
Tapper or not
baby let's go it's a heavyweight fight
tonight you know what I want though
truly oh my God I want this to land on
14 so everybody wins I can't wait until
he ends with 14. and that's gonna be
awesome
that would be dope if that actually 15
it can land off it what do you got 15
and a half yeah yeah yeah make Atlanta
um but yeah right it's not you bro I
just want you to know that like leaving
this show it's not you bro it's the
Capper it's literally uh literally just
rotten with the guy okay that was like a
that was like a a Good Will Hunting type
of like it's not your fault type of deal
that was yeah
I appreciate it boom
salute salute
um all right guys
I think we gave all our Best Bets we
locked in the parlay Ryan if you can I
know you don't like to do this bro after
that after that
if you can just say the parlay one more
time for the people that might have just
joined before we get a party I know ah I
wish we locked this in earlier it's all
good uh Jimmy Butler one plus steel bam
out of Bio one plus block uh Nikolai
jokic one plus block Nikolai jokic over
six and a half alternate assists you
guessed it Nikolai jokic over one and a
half made threes and then Aaron Gordon
over four and a half alternate rebounds
six legs it ended at plus 901 six seven
six six
um six um six of them six of them there
it is there it is there you guys go in
the lines fluctuating it's gonna move up
and down
um make sure you guys
screenshot make sure you guys screenshot
it make sure you guys screenshot it uh
ride with this ride with this Ryan's
rocking with Caleb Martin under 15 and a
half points rebalance my boy bowling got
the Jamal Murray 40 plus points in any
NBA Finals game and sitting at plus 2700
oh bowling like that plus money I like
it I like it and I was like
it's not right I'm following the Capper
I'm following somebody I talked to
earlier and I'm going with over 13 and a
half points in rebounds for Caleb Martin
fellas it's been fun it was fun it was
fun it was a fun show it was a fun show
you guys feeling good as we as we exit
here
I'm feeling different for sure we we're
not packing a bag for Miami y'all this
is over with no yeah yeah
they might go to Miami next week to go
to live and party but they're not going
for a game this one's over with yeah the
NBC in this one's over with I'm
I got the heat so I don't want to agree
with you but my heart does you know so
um
I Heard the I heard the clients are
cheaper to Cancun from Denver so I think
it's probably
it's probably just Eastern end of the
snap
yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah funny hey my name is Greg Ivory
though my name is Greg Ivory we're about
to get up out of here it's time to go
win some money my name is Greg Arby next
to me to your left is the guy we like to
call producer Ryan and then to your
right over there did I get it right yep
I got it right here we go over there yep
is the man I like to call him MB y'all
might call him Michael Bowen he is the
man of the app uh we are out of here
let's win some money tonight fellas
peace
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]